الثقافه تترجم بعده لغات ولغه الطعام هي
الاغنى والالذ للشعوب العالم دليل الاطعمه
والمشروبات والاطباق التقليديات تيست اطلس
اصدر قيمته السنويه لافضل المطابخ حول
العالم لعام 2022 القائمه الشهيه لمطابخ
العالم اثارت جدلا واسعا واستقبلت
بانتقادات اللاذعه عبر تويتر وانستغرام
تسال المتابعون كيف ياتي المطبخ الامريكي
في المركز الثامن بينما مثلا المطبخ
المغربي في المركز الرابع و90 وقبل الاخير
في القائمه
المستخدمون معترضون ايضا بسبب ان نحو نصف
القائمه من المطابخ الاوروبيه ربما ما
الشيء الوحيد الذي اتفقوا عليه هو ان
المطبخ الايطالي يستحق ان يكون في الصداره
كما جاء في ذلك للعام عربيا المطبخ
الجزائري في المركز الرابع والثلاثين
سوريا في المركز السابع والثلاثين بينما
المطبخ اللبناني بالمرتبه الاربعين
[موسيقى]
السوري والترجي واللبناني عادي اطيب مطبخ
اي اكل احب اكثر بعد الاكل لبناني
الاكل اللبناني الفلسطيني فيلم سخان
الخليجي العراقي
في اكثر من شيء في المغرب كمان عندهم
السمك وعندهم اللحوم كل شيء طيب المغرب